[Música]
parafraseando a italo calvino diré que
las ciudades son un conjunto de muchas
cosas
ritmos cadencias signos de un lenguaje
son espacios de trueque simbólicos no
son solo de mercancías
son trueques de palabras de recuerdos de
memorias
hace cuatro años ya que me mudé de mi
ciudad natal matamoros tamaulipas
pertenezco a un fenómeno muy común de
los jóvenes que estudian la preparatoria
local y me mudé a otro estado a terminar
mi carrera universitaria
matamoros es una ciudad fronteriza
situada al noreste de méxico y que como
muchas otras pequeñas ciudades sufrió la
violencia y fue azotada terriblemente
hace algunos años
las ejecuciones las desapariciones y los
secuestros era un tema de conversación
continuamente en nuestras casas en
nuestras escuelas y con nuestros amigos
del trabajo también
y digo esto porque creo firmemente que
nuestro punto de partida también nos
define
las casas en las que crecimos las calles
en las que jugamos los barrios nuestras
pequeñas ciudades
siempre ha habido discursos encontrados
en las migraciones me voy porque no me
gusta mi ciudad
me quedé porque nunca pude irme
la nostalgia de extrañar el hogar la
dicha de nunca volverá al pueblo cuando
hablo sobre la violencia que azotó
nuestras pequeñas ciudades es una
historia común y conocida estamos
relacionados con ella o cuando hablo
sobre lo que nos falta o lo aburridas
que son también nuestras pequeñas
ciudades nos hace sentido porque es la
narrativa la que hemos estado expuestos
ha sido reforzada por los medios y
también nosotros hacemos chistes sobre
nuestros baches sobre el rancho sobre lo
inseguro que son que son nuestras
ciudades
como dije compartimos y reproducimos
estos estigmas
y hay que ser honestos
todos y todas participamos de una
narrativa divisionista y reduccionista
sobre el papel de nuestras pequeñas
ciudades aspiramos a ser metrópolis
queremos ser sitios turísticos queremos
más calles más avenidas más plazas
comerciales más cadenas o franquicias
internacionales nos emocionamos cuando
llega a starbucks
pero quien dijo y quien nos enseñó que
esto define que una ciudad sea ciudad
por supuesto que no se trata de ignorar
las violencias o las desigualdades
sociales la planificación urbana o la
falta de espacios públicos pero por el
contrario se pone de manifiesto conocer
mejor el potencial y la historia de
nuestras pequeñas ciudades
amo mi ciudad amo que mi ciudad sea
pequeña porque todos nos conocemos entre
sí sabemos quién es quién hay redes muy
complejas entretejidas entre familiares
amigos y de parejas
amo mi ciudad amo la cercanía al mar y
poder ir a nadar tranquilamente un
domingo a la playa comer mariscos
frescos e ir a las carreras del o2 las
dunas de arena
amo la cercanía con estados unidos y lo
que posibilita que seamos vecinos la
mezcla de culturas lo mex a lo chica no
el ser bilingües
re imaginemos y resignificamos nuestras
ciudades visualicemos nuestros
prejuicios y pongamos de moda amar lo
nuestro y hacer proyectos de
transformación quise hacer un pequeño
sondeo para ilustrar un poco
estos prejuicios ciudadanos de los que
les hablaba me contestaron
me contestaron 100 personas de alrededor
de 28 ciudades del país
la primera pregunta que siempre quise
hacer fue te han dicho alguna vez que tu
ciudad es un rancho
95 personas respondieron que sí
y creo que esto ilustra un poco sobre
cómo nos respetamos y cómo nos
denigramos desde pequeños siempre nos
enseñaron esa ecuación esos dos polos
pues rancho o es ciudad no hubo lugar
para más matices
pero bueno después del insulto al rancho
la pregunta era si alguien ofendiera tu
ciudad serías capaz de anunciar algo
bueno para defenderla
el 90% respondió que si a mucha honra
quiero decir aquí que he visto muchas
veces a muchos amigos ponerse nerviosos
y sudorosos tratando de enunciar algo
que no los haga quedar en ridículo no
como algún artista que nació ahí algún
platillo típico regional algo que nos
identifique como si la vida fuera una
competencia como si no tuviéramos
referentes culturales completamente
distintos y las identidades no se
construyeran de diferentes maneras y
pienso que cansado competir todo el
tiempo en lugar de poner esa energía en
proyectos que transformen nuestras
ciudades
la tercera pregunta que quise hacer fue
en una escala del 1 al 5 que tanto
conoces la historia de tu ciudad
la mayoría respondieron que 3 y la
verdad es que tampoco aún deben
verificar y preguntarles sobre el año de
su fundación o preguntarles la
relevancia o el papel que jugó en la
independencia o la revolución porque
creo que de por sí en un sistema
escolarizado es difícil aprender sobre
historia universal o se complica
aprender sobre historia de méxico cuanto
más en la historia local no y luego en
un contexto globalizado donde los
relatos y los cronistas cada vez
desaparecen más será que todo está
perdido yo creo que no en realidad
vivimos en la era de la información
o la era del manejo de la información
más bien el verdadero reto es aprender a
gestionarla para que llegue cada vez a
más personas
un nuevo un muy buen amigo mío tiene un
proyecto de hecho que tiene que ver con
historia local armar unos cursos de
historia local para llevarlos a las
primarias y formar esta ciudadanía
consciente desde pequeños además incluye
un tour por los principales museos de la
localidad siempre hay maneras y me
parece extraordinario hablando de los
museos la siguiente pregunta fue visitas
regularmente las exposiciones de museos
en tu ciudad
80 respondieron que no la mayoría cuando
formule esta pregunta me acordé de mí a
los 14 años y lo interesante y lo
maravilloso que fue involucrarme con el
arte y con los proyectos culturales
dejaron una huella en mí y me marcaron
de por vida hace poco leía un artículo
en la revista del país que se llamaba
los museos son el templo de la
modernidad y entrelíneas alto una frase
que me gustó mucho que decía cuidado con
el arte puede despertar emociones en
nosotros que creíamos escondidas y creo
que esto es maravilloso porque importa
si vas al museo y te tomas una selphy o
subes una història instagram que muchas
muchas personas critican esto qué bueno
pongamos de moda ir a los museos el
museo es un espacio para una especie de
experiencia cultural colectiva y
espiritual única en su tipo
luego quise preguntar sobre la estética
lo bonito no a veces nos importa
muchísimo que nuestra ciudad sea
atractiva pero ya sabemos de manifiesto
que la estética y lo bello siempre ha
estado en debate y que es relativo
entonces con tantas referencias
distintas de lo que es belleza como
construimos una ciudad o como logramos
tener una ciudad que sea estéticamente
bella para todos y para todas si yo
fuera un profesor ahorita el reto sería
reunirse en equipo y diseñen una ciudad
que sea estéticamente bella y el gran
reto es la solidaridad no la cooperación
que no dejen a nadie fuera es un gran
reto encontrar belleza en la diversidad
la sexta pregunta es interesante porque
pone pone en evidencia muchísimos de los
prejuicios que tenemos si pudieras hacer
que tu ciudad se pareciera a alguna otra
qué ciudad sería
dubai ámsterdam misa barcelona ciudad de
mexico parís/madrid y me encantó una una
respuesta en particular que decía como
orlando florida pero con un poquito de
guanajuato
qué interesante
la última pregunta es para ustedes me
gustaría que pensarán
cuál es su lugar o su espacio favorito
en sus ciudades
puede ser el lugar donde dieron su
primer beso el parque en donde se
escapaban y ya cuando se hacían la pinta
de la escuela el café donde terminaron
de leer su primer libro
puede ser cualquiera de esos
amo mi ciudad la amo profundamente pero
sé que no es el común denominador
la gran pregunta que entonces surge es
cómo logramos tener una mejor relación
con nuestras pequeñas ciudades cómo
lograr resultados distintos a las
preguntas anteriores
hay que ocupar nuestros espacios la
participación ciudadana y el
involucramiento en proyectos de
transformación hace una distinción
enorme entre quienes son habitantes de
quienes son visitantes y personas en
tránsito
no todas las ciudades son sitios
turísticos o metrópolis y no tienen por
qué serlo en realidad la ciudad de las
formas de habitar la han sido resultado
de procesos muy complejos guerras
comerciales revoluciones sociales
dictaduras corrientes artísticas
persecuciones religiosas revoluciones
sexuales y muchísimas otras la ciudad
irremediablemente es social
la idea del centro periferia que
acontece en méxico entiéndase los
provincianos y los capitalinos tiene
efectos en el imaginario colectivo como
si el monopolio del progreso la
civilización el conocimiento lo tuvieran
solo ciertas ciudades con aeropuertos y
vuelos internacionales como si el
asfalto y el concreto fueran adjetivos
inherentes al buen vivir
el nuestro es un mundo lleno de
contradicciones en donde conviven viejos
y nuevos modelos en algunas ciudades
construyen azoteas verdes para mitigar
la contaminación y en otras ciudades no
dejamos de generar más y más tráfico en
algunas ciudades los colectivos luchan
por privilegiar a los peatones y en
otras ciudades seguimos diseñando
puentes peatonales pasos a desnivel para
privilegiar al automóvil en algunas
ciudades diseñan innovaciones
tecnológicas para abastecerse con agua
de lluvia
por la falta del vital líquido y en
otras ciudades seguimos gastando y
gastando sin falta de conciencia
ojo no sugiero que compararnos y
contrastar sea malo per se pero juzgar
desde la desinformación y desde los
prejuicios no es justo ni benéfico para
nadie
quiero decir que no es ciudad sino es
para todas y para todos y esto es
importante porque hay que aprender a
escucharnos
ricos pobres blancos negros skaters
académicos intelectuales
lg católicos religiosos todos y todas
somos parte de la misma ciudad y
necesitamos participar en el diseño de
las mismas
el nuestro también es un mundo
conocimientos en la meritocracia nos han
enseñado a competir ya ganar siempre
habrá que reeducarnos en la cooperación
y la solidaridad no hay otra forma en la
que podamos lograr esto giremos el
discurso posicionamos una narrativa de
lo que sí es posible
la ciudad pequeña tiene esta posibilidad
de ser pensada como algo más que
espacios deshabitados violencia y
desigualdad económica las violencias
existen pero si sólo hablamos de ellas
limitamos la narrativa de la paz del
arte y de los proyectos de
transformación cultural la gente emigra
pero si sólo hablamos de los que se
fueron y los que se van limitamos la
narrativa e invalidados la historia de
quien decidió quedarse a construir una
mejor ciudad
necesitamos mejores políticos mejores
servidores públicos necesitamos que se
acabe la corrupción pero también
nosotros podemos ser mejores ciudadanos
con demandas más articuladas con
exigencias más especializadas y
construyendo proyectos desde lo local
la comunidad dice liliana lópez borbón
no se encuentra preelaborada ni en una
universidad ni por ir a la misma iglesia
ni siquiera por vivir en el mismo barrio
construir comunidad requiere de tiempo
involucramiento y respeto
construyamos una comunidad
propongo que conozcamos y socialicemos
nuestra historia local no desde una
perspectiva de fijación con el pasado ni
de medel a futuro fobia pero para tener
un punto de partida otra herramienta que
alimente y nutra nuestras identidades
colectivas
cada ciudad es un ecosistema distinto y
tiene impresos en sus calles y sus
ciudades diferentes textos que están
cambiando día con día
hoy es un buen día para cuestionarlos lo
conocido es un buen día para re imaginar
y resignificar nuestras ciudades si
queremos que algo cambie necesitamos
movernos del lugar gracias
[Aplausos]